l a tutti ragazzi è pervenuti a questo
nuovo video io non sono felice io in
realtà sono yoda ed oggi siamo tornati
suo amico di rotta ragazzi era da tanto
che non facevo migo il tipo è passato
all'incirca più di un anno se non
sbaglio la l'ultima volta che l'ho fatto
quindi sono un po emozionato nel rifarlo
chi non sapesse ragazzi amico le un sito
dove si possono incontrare fan
dipende da cosa viene utilizzato quindi
ragazzi basta premesse perché non sto
più nella pelle quindi cominciamo che è
meglio d'accordo ragazzi ci siamo detti
di scrivere la frase lasciate ogni
speranza voi che entrate suo amico
sperando di incontrare justin bieber a
tutti coloro che volevano partecipare
quindi chi scrive questa frase adesso
dovrebbe apparirmi nel video ecco io
sono bellissimo a riga che è esplosa una
bomba buonasera buonasera buonasera sono
le quattro non sa che buonasera questo è
proprio da frate a benevento ci
mancherebbe altro mi metto viene niente
un'altra un'altra il calendario qui che
che era il gatto ma che addio cecchetto
è la finestra ma che tiene i ragazzini
chiusi nella ma chi è che mi sembra di
vedere l'alba dei morti viventi non
visto l'altro giorno ma certo ma se
bravo bravo stai facendo il video a
presto ok che faccio schifo però un po
più di d'atto nelle
[Musica]
certo effetto che faccio la mattina
quando mi faccio vedere la mia mamma che
sono spettinato registrando vero no non
sto registrando ragazzi è stato un
piacere
[Musica]
questo è il pezzo dove devi fare questa
cosa sono come si come ti chiami ali
sociali io sono venuta anche
all'incontro con dio thoth che è la foto
su messenger è dovuto detto sembra che
mi guardi le tette una cosa del genere
io mi vedere questa foto mandamelo
immediatamente
io non guardo le tette alle ragazze
questa cosa non sfatiamo questo mito aaa
a c
vabbè tesoro e non è che sto guardando
solo evidentemente guardando la collana
così ma buone diciamo ma che discorsi
sono alice ma che cosa stiamo parlando e
che il problema c'è ma ti pare ci
rincontriamo di nuovo metto gli occhiali
certo ci mancherebbe altro
siamo belle grazie anch'io son contento
e per tutto il tempo di questa chiamata
io ti ho guardato gli occhi
[Musica]
tipo una vecchia che si sta assaggiando
il capezzolo ero sistemava madonna che
spavento perché ci credo che tu non
parli favi a me lo ricordo io li ho
visti tutti i video e devo dire che non
me lo ricordo questo video
sei molto scaltro grande uomo porca favi
che vi sta vedendo la mia condivisione
sa pure che non puoi avere il mio stesso
paio di cuffie non esiste
ho preso quando dicevi 600mila e screen
da quanto cazzo ti spiego tutto madonna
grande sì mamma vieni qua come mamma
vieni qua ma ora sto parlando con lui la
grecia mamma ciao salve che bello vedere
anche adesso spetta aspetti aspetti che
un giorno mi faceva ridere il contesto
bella tutti i ragazzi che il cappellini
cappellino signora io guardi cio vasta
scelta o di partito justin bieber mi
scusi e scelga disponiamo di vasta
scelta non lo lancia luogo del gattino
giallo questo di totoro mi scriva che
glielo invio mi ha fatto piacere caro
amico mio ciao salve ariete che bello
dei ragazzi come voi siete fantastici
animali per quasi a come stai
ok nome che non avevo pensato però il
carino borello tutto bene cazzo meno
allora hai qualcos'altro nel tuo
repertorio di frasi e partiamo cazzo
io ti prego dimmi che da vero dubbio
sono o cazzo perché io so che se va bene
se devo chiamare la mia milioni che se
hai bisogno di respirare in un sacchetto
per non svenire cazzo e siamo a tre
donna ha una palla coppa v day
0 0 e va dai ciao non ti sento però vedo
che i miti quindi siamo a posto
oddio oddio che si trovano i capelli zio
avvicinati un po alla webcam amici nati
ecco da un po più indietro deve deve
deve diventare bianco ecco io mi
sembrava che se si entra in un super
sayan ti ho qualcosa che ti seguo da i
tempi di due sardi gaming ma dai
veramente grandi
parla ti prego se non ci crederà mai
arienti vedo parla che lei mainente
spera il leggero aspetta adesso ti
faccio una foto rilevando aspetta va
bene purtroppo buono sono caz che
rischiamo le date del matrimonio sia
dipende se se posso giocare alla
playstation
tutto il tempo prima che entri sempre
anche come anche come dove sei stata
dove sei stata cara base ciao carissima
ma va a colori e il mio armadio è il mio
armadio in camera
oddio ferma per merito se via la sedia
brasilia insomma come possibile sa cosa
ho fatto per la mia sedia come file
avere ogni armadio ma è anche jazz email
versione donna non siamo la stessa cosa
in questo momento che io non so questo
décolleté sai che se tu metti la webcam
la gente pensa che siano stati appunto
nicky nicolai lombardi ppd che mi
somigli pure con questi lunghi capelli
biondi
ciao ciao ragazzo aveva le mie stesse
che è pazzesco
ci siamo incontrati due volte dal vivo
veramente ragazzo bellissimo è la forza
del capezzolo tragara alla prossima
ciao caro come stai ai capelli
disordinati dei miei la mattina però è
comunque è un piacere
sì però ascoltami già stai messo male i
capelli non stare a fare cose faccio
faccio il bravo bravo perfetto
no è una roba che se facciamo a gara non
so chi vince ma di chi in posa e mette
in posa arrivo
e stato un piacere comunque cavani sono
io
justin bieber justin ho sempre voluto
vederti suo mega fermo voglio una forza
così vuole una posa sexy da justin
bieber devo fare una forza teksid a
justin bieber
aspetta aspetta che prova a imitare lo
aspetta che respira sono giapponese no
no no no è un fake
no non ti credo è un fake non a non fare
foto così del momento mi posa prima
grande è stato un piacere di vederti
caramia la cosa che ti volevo dire che
basta capito palco ha dato al bellissimo
resto ti piace il mio tatuaggio è
bellissimo ma grazie ancora foto va bene
ciao
che cosa sei
c'è un umano lì sotto ma cos'è tesoro
ascoltano adesso si ascolta ascolta un
attimo ultimamente fa un po più freddo
perché ottobre sai ma sti cazzi cioè nel
senso prendi una felpa non è che mi ti
devi in bardare manco fossi tutankhamon
nel 2015
ciao ciao macero va bene ragazzi
concluso che l'episodio è stata io
potrei continuare veramente tutto il
giorno a fare sta roba perché mi diverto
io mi diverto come un deficiente a farlo
non lo so perché veramente io vi
ringrazio di essere sempre così
affettuosi perché dio mio è una cosa
bellissima non ve lo sa neanche
descrivere
ragazzi vi giuro vi ringrazio di essere
sempre così meravigliosi con me ed è una
cosa veramente incredibile grazie grazie
grazie
io concludo più episodio ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto come al
solito seguito è piaciuto accertamento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
co nei video tratta descrizione dei
signori cities che ci vediamo al
prossimo video ragazzi